.
TO THAT PROBLEM.
[APPLAUSE]
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT IS NOT A
GOOD SOLUTION IS HAVING POLICE
COULD BE INVESTIGATING UNSOLVED
RAPES AND MURDERS GET DISTRACTED
WITH PAPERWORK TO GIVE CITATIONS
TO PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE ANY
WHERE TO USE THE TOILET IN
PRIVATE.
>> Tucker: OH, SO THERE IS
HUMAN FECES ON THE SIDEWALK BUT
IT IS IT IS YOUR FAULT FOR NOT
BUILDING TOILETS.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE
SAN FRANCISCO VOTERS SENT
YESTERDAY AND THE REASON THEY
WERE ABLE TO TRACE THIS BACK TOA
MAN CALLED DAVID SACKS, ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO FUNDED THIS
RECALL ELECTION.
HE IS THE COFOUNDER -- ALSO THE
FORMER CEO OF PAYPAL AND HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM JOIN US TONIGHT TO
CELEBRATE THE TRIUMPH OF
DEMOCRACY IN THE CITY OF
SENTENCES GO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WERE YOU SURPRISED BY THE
MARGINS HERE SMACK THEY SEEM
HUGE GIVEN THE CITY.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU, TUCKER,
GREAT TO BE HERE.
BOUDIN TRIED TO FRAME THIS AS A
REPUBLICAN RECALL AND CALLED IT
TRUMPIST, BUT ONLY -- IT IS A
90% DEMOCRAT CITY.
A 60% MAJORITY SHOWS YOU
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS AND
MODERATES THROUGHOUT THE CITY
EJECTED THE RADICAL PROGRESSIVE
AGENDA.
SOME BOUNDARY LINES ARE BEING
DRAWN INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WERE AVERAGE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS ARE STARTING
TO PUSH BACK AGAINST THE
ACTIVISTS AND THE WOKE
BILLIONAIRES, THE DONOR CLASS,
THE UNIONS, THE SPECIAL
INTEREST, WHO ARE TRYING TO PUSH
AN AGENDA OUT OF STEP EVEN WITH
THE LIBERAL CITIZENS OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Tucker: WELL, EXACTLY.
THIS IS SOME SORT OF TRUMPIST
EFFORT, WHATEVER YOUR POLITICS
ARE, YOU STEPPED IN AND GAVE
VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN BECAUSE IT IS AN EMERGENCY
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN YOUR CITY,
I THINK IT IS FAIR TO SAY.
YOU JUST ALLOWED DEMOCRACY TO
TAKE PLACE.
HOW COULD ANYONE COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT?
>> RIGHT, AND IT WAS NOT JUST
ME.
THERE WERE MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO CONTRIBUTED, WHO ARE
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS.
IT IS VERY MUCH A BROAD-BASED
EFFORT, PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO
REJECTING THEIR SORT OF RADICAL
D CARSON RATION US AGENDA WHERE
CHESA BOUDIN DEAN HAD THIS
IDEA THEY COULD MAKE
SAN FRANCISCO SAFER BY
DECREASING THE PRISON POPULATION
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE, THEY CALL
IT DECARCERATION.
WE ARE LIVING WITH THE COMES
ONCE IS THAT AND SAN FRANCISCANS
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE ARE
REJECTING THAT AGENDA.
THE ACTIVIST WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY COMMITMENT TO
TAKE MORE THAN ONE ELECTION FOR
THEM TO REJECT IT.
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
REPLICATED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
YOU HONESTLY DON'T -- AND YOU
FOLLOW THIS CLOSELY -- IF THEY
LOSE IN SAN FRANCISCO, THAT'S
NOT A CLEAR LEFT MESSAGE FOR
THEM?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU
HAVE THE SORT OF DECARERCERAL
PROSECUTORS ELECTED IN L.A.,
THEY ARE BACKED BY BILLIONAIRES,
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS
BECAUSE OF ONE ELECTION, THEY
MAY CHANGE -- IT'S GOING TO TAKE
EFFORT IN MANY OF THESE CITIES.
TO TRY AND MAKE A CHANGE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT IS MEANT
TO TAKE DEMOCRACY.
DAVI